[Aplausos]
[Música]
chóferes coches oficiales asesores
secretarias secretarios teléfonos
móviles billetes de avión buenos
despachos peluquería servicios de
mayordomo y un sueldo más que generoso
equivalente a entre 15 y 20 salarios
mínimos cada mes esta es la vida de los
representantes de el pueblo en un país
como la argentina donde ya casi el 50%
de la población vive en la pobreza y
donde el salario medio apenas supera los
300 dólares
en otras palabras queridos amigos y
amigas si queréis vivir el sueño
argentino vais a tener que dedicarnos a
la política en el país del tango los
asados y los rescates financieros y si
éste es otro vídeo sobre la argentina un
país que se está convirtiendo en todo un
más de visual político pero que queréis
que os diga cómo se dice por esos lares
no para de darnos letras y es que amigos
podríamos pensar como suele decir por
cierto el presidente alberto fernández
que todo esto del coste de la política
es un tema menor o pura demagogia claro
que eso sería así si los políticos
argentinos pues no estuvieran siendo los
responsables de destruir un país al
tiempo que están convirtiendo la
argentina en una especie de resort cinco
estrellas para los miembros de este
selecto club
y ojo amigos porque hablamos de la
argentina aquí la política es mucho más
pesada de lo que te puedas llegar a
imaginar
[Música]
amigos amigas argentinas lleva tres años
sumida en una dura recesión económica en
2018 la economía que hay un 25 por
ciento en 2019 122 y en 2020 pandemia
por medio un 12 por ciento y no se trata
sólo del pib prácticamente todos los
indicadores son malos la pobreza no deja
de crecer el déficit público está por
encima del 6% y la inflación
bueno lo de la inflación argentina como
ya os hemos contado se escapa de toda
lógica económica con crisis sanitaria o
sin ella el gobierno no deja de darle a
la máquina de imprimir billetes una y
otra y otra y otra vez lo que
técnicamente en economía se llama
expandir la oferta monetaria hasta
llevarla a la estratosfera pues bien a
pesar de todo ello los políticos
argentinos no han sido capaces de tener
ni un solo gesto ya sabéis la demagogia
no sé tal vez el hecho de que la mayoría
de los políticos pues hayan vivido casi
siempre de papá estados les ha hecho
levantar a sal una coraza a una muralla
que les protege de los problemas que
están consumiendo al país ya sabéis
nunca nada es culpa suya a pesar de
ellos algunas fuentes autorizadas como
por ejemplo el economista roberto que
están los que llevan ya tiempo
reclamando una reducción drástica del
coste de la estructura política una
reducción que mejoraría la cada vez más
deteriorada percepción de la política al
tiempo que libería las exiguas arcas
públicas quién sabe incluso quizás
reducir el coste burocrático y político
y bajar algún que otro punto los
impuestos que afectan a la actividad
productiva en uno de los países de todo
el mundo con los impuestos a las
empresas más altos no sé igual hasta
sería una buena idea ahí lo dejo ahora
bien se puede realmente reducir el coste
de la política en argentina de que carga
exactamente estamos hablando cuál sería
la mejor forma de reducir este gasto y
mejorar su eficiencia y una pregunta no
menos importante podría mejorar la vida
de los argentinos echan el cierre a la
argentina luxury resort 5 estrellas para
políticos pues bien
veámoslo
[Música]
una estructura de capa sobre capa lo
primero todo un apunte que tenemos que
tener en cuenta especialmente si nos
estás viendo desde la argentina entre
los años 1930 y 1983 este país se pasó
la mitad del tiempo bajo regímenes
militares en cierto modo eso explica que
una vez que la democracia se recuperó en
1983 cualquier cosa que tuviera que ver
con ella fuera inviolable simplemente no
se podía criticar
de esta forma a cualquier comentario
negativo era visto como toda una
declaración antidemocrática y los
políticos se aprovecharon de ello sin
embargo amigos estamos ya en la segunda
década del siglo 21 así que lo siento
pero ya no cuela
ah
a criticar una forma de hacer política
no supone criticar la democracia al
contrario la opacidad la falta de
transparencia y la falta de crítica
generan impunidad que es el mejor
ingrediente posible para el abuso pero
de qué estamos hablando exactamente pues
fijaos para entendernos vamos a tomar
como referencia el tipo de cambio de
mercado del peso argentino con el dólar
en el momento de preparar este vídeo
aproximadamente unos 85 pesos por cada
dólar pues bien de esta forma el salario
mínimo viene a ser de 212 dólares
mensuales el salario de un policía de
540 dólares el de una enfermera de 470 y
el de un maestro de poco más de 300 en
total según el instituto nacional de
estadística y censos de la república
argentina entre la población ocupada el
ingreso medio fue de 365 dólares y el
ingreso mediano ojo importante esto es
el ingreso que se sitúa justo en la
mitad y un 50% de los ingresos por
debajo y un 50 por ciento por encima fue
de tan sólo 294 dólares para que os
hagáis una idea por ejemplo el salario
mediano en españa es de unos 1.700
dólares 6,5 veces más alto y os hablamos
de españa con otros países como francia
dos unidos o canadá pues mejor no hablar
amigos siento decirlo pero los números
del otrora país más rico del planeta son
simple y llanamente desolador es claro
que un momento porque la situación entre
los políticos es algo diferente ojo más
que un dato concreto fijaos en cómo capa
tras capa la política argentina se ha
convertido en todo un elefante muy caro
de mantener para las arcas públicas
[Música]
para no complicar demasiado la cosa
vamos a centrarnos en el caso del
congreso nacional tened en cuenta que la
situación es similar a la que podemos
encontrar en el resto de órganos
políticos pues bien el congreso nacional
consta de una cámara de diputados- con
257 integrantes y un senado con 72
representantes su presupuesto del
congreso nacional para el año 2021 es de
algo más de 470 millones de dólares lo
que resulta en que cada uno de los 329
representantes le cuestan por año los
argentinos la friolera de un millón 428
mil 571 dólares en promedio aunque si
entramos en detalle el coste por senador
es mucho más alto que el de un diputado
evidentemente esto incluye muchas
partidas de todo tipo como asesores
catering o no sé quizás peluquería y si
de hecho el congreso nacional tiene su
propia peluquería a disposición de sus
señorías y de hecho una vez que éstos
han cumplido su mandato según el
artículo 9 de la ley 20 1984 pues pueden
seguir disfrutando de instalaciones como
el comedor o la peluquería
luego a nivel de sueldos a primera vista
la cosa parece menos llamativa el
salario de un diputado o un senador por
ejemplo ronda los dos mil quinientos
dólares mensuales mucho menos por
ejemplo que en españa pero un momento
amigos no nos despistemos recordad que
estamos hablando de la argentina un país
en el salario mediano es de poco más de
290 dólares es decir que el salario de
un congresista equivale a 9,5 salarios
medianos en términos relativos es como
si en españa un diputado pues cobrará de
media 16 mil dólares mensuales pero
evidentemente eso no es lo peor lo más
llamativo es que en el senado trabajan
mil 470 personas 20 personas por cada
senador y en la cámara de diputados
otras 2 mil 161 que vienen a resultar
ocho personas por cada diputado
[Música]
de hecho el coste real por diputado
teniendo en cuenta salarios
móviles colaboradores transporte
etcétera etcétera viene a ser de unos 40
mil dólares mensuales un 60 por ciento
más que en españa en términos absolutos
y en el caso de los senadores la cifra
se dispara hasta los 140 mil dólares por
mes siete veces más que su coste
equivalente en españa' todo en términos
absolutos de cuestiones relativas mejor
no hablemos y por supuesto tampoco es
que españa un país tres veces más rico
que argentina sea un ejemplo de
austeridad vamos en otras palabras que
sus señorías tienen que estar muy pero
que muy bien atendidos ya sabéis
argentina luxury hotel cinco estrellas
para políticos el récord lo tiene el
senador roberto basualdo de la alianza
cambiemos sanjuán con 60 colaboradores
directos le sigue luís naidenoff con 48
empleados
roberto cachanosky economista argentino
por supuesto como muchos os estaréis
imaginando en este preciso momento
muchas de estas personas son parientes
amigos y colaboradores políticos sin
ninguna o escasa cualificación
profesional para esa labor de
asesoramiento tan importante que
supuestamente realizan
eso es todo
[Aplausos]
según un informe de canal el centro de
apertura para el desarrollo de américa
latina los mayores aumentos de personal
se registraron en otras áreas del poder
legislativo como por ejemplo la imprenta
del congreso que tiene de acuerdo con el
presupuesto de 2018
639 empleados un 18% más que en 2016
pese a que estamos en plena era digital
en la que las impresiones en papel se
vienen reduciendo significativamente en
todo el mundo por su parte la biblioteca
tiene ojo más de 1.700 trabajadores un
80% más en 2004
1700 trabajadores en la biblioteca no se
me gustaría saber qué demonios hacen por
supuesto se sospecha que la mayoría son
simples militantes políticos ya sabéis
cómo funciona esto
el preso expresado él se enchufa y luego
se quedan ahí de por vida ya sabéis son
empleados públicos
[Música]
quizás lo más sorprendente de todo es
que según el recuento del periodista
agustín karely en 2019 antes de la
pandemia el congreso apenas tuvo diez
sesiones entre el senado y la cámara de
diputados en fin me vais a permitir
decirlo un auténtico disparate pero es
sólo un ejemplo tan solo hemos hablado
del congreso nacional pero lo cierto es
que este tipo de estructuras caras
sobredimensionadas y sin sentido se
repiten constantemente el tamaño del
estado de argentina está completamente
fuera de control y el resultado el
resultado ya lo habéis visto un salario
mediano de poco más de 290 dólares una
crisis constante casi un 50 por ciento
de pobreza y unos impuestos que se
sitúan entre los más altos del mundo en
argentina amigos los mayores privilegios
recaen en políticos y sindicatos tal
como ya vimos en un pasado vídeo aquí en
visual político fijaos por ejemplo en el
caso de cristina fernández de kirchner y
no hoy no os voy a hablar de corrupción
no al menos de lo que legalmente se
entiende como corrupción
el juez federal ezequiel pérez na me
autorizó a la hoy vicepresidenta a
cobrar al mismo tiempo la jubilación
vitalicia exenta de impuestos a la que
tiene derecho por haber sido presidenta
junto a la pensión de su difunto marido
también ex presidente y su actual
salario como vicepresidenta en total más
de 24.000 dólares mensuales
[Música]
bien 100 veces el salario mediano no me
digáis que eso no es montarse lo bien y
ojo porque eso no es todo también le ha
reconocido el derecho a percibir un pago
de 12 millones de dólares por las
pensiones atrasadas menudo chollo la
política argentina pero insisto lo peor
de argentina no son los casos aislados
sino sobre todo el modelo de país que
los políticos han construido para su
propio beneficio
por ejemplo han empleado hasta la
saciedad la estrategia política de
comprar votos y hoy entre unas cosas y
otras más de la mitad de la población
recibe algún tipo de pago directo o
indirecto del estado pagos como salarios
subsidios o pensiones más de la mitad de
la población lo que evidentemente es
inviable y ojo porque no olvidéis que no
es precisamente un estado de bienestar
lo que se ha construido en argentina
sino de pobreza la pobreza en argentina
subió al 44 2% y alcanza a 18 millones
de personas son datos del observatorio
de deuda social de la uca sobre el
tercer trimestre del 2020 en un año se
sumaron 2 millones de nuevos pobres en
vigencia totalizó el 10,1 por ciento en
fin de verdad os doy mi palabra' cuanto
lo siento por un país tan estupendo como
la argentina un país amigos que
represento el sueño de millones de
personas que viajaron hasta allí desde
el viejo continente en busca de libertad
y prosperidad el sueño roto del que una
vez fue el país más rico y desarrollado
de todo el mundo y por cierto mucho ojo
a todos los que nos veis desde españa
hay muchas diferencias sí pero también
muchas similitudes en fin si este vídeo
ha resultado interesante no olvidéis
darle al botón de like y suscribir
abisal político una vez más muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]